allegations of bullying have followed
the Deputy Prime Minister around
confident
[Music]
for months
[Applause]
Dominic Raab on the defense I will
thoroughly rebut and refute any of the
claims that be made I've behaved
professionally at all times you insist
you are not a bully but do you accept
that others think you are well I'm
course engaged with the inquiry and will
not comment on it at all while that
inquiry continue I've spoken
to Rob
as to themselves
but these are their accounts of his
behavior we asked actors to voice the
following testimony his was the worst
behavior I have ever seen the way he
would treat people the little people
interrogate people ignore people he
created an awful atmosphere it was
coercive Behavior he had people in tears
after coming out of his office but they
wouldn't want to complain they saw it as
Professional Pride just to cope with it
he wouldn't shout but he'd be so angry
quiet Fury the vein would be pumping on
his head and he would look like he was
about to explode
Mr Robb has always maintained he behaved
professionally that high standards don't
make you a bully others allege they saw
different he never tried this on me but
in the private office of Junior
officials he put the fear of God into
them
they were nervous about going into
meetings with him because they feared
having strips torn off them or an
unpleasant encounter it was not a good
place to be
as complaints emerged last year MPS who
worked with Mr Rob across departments
sought to defend him Helen Grant MP
tweeted to say I witnessed a very decent
hard-working minister with high
Professional Standards and a solid work
ethic Dominic has zero tolerance for
bullying and Eddie Hughes MP said we got
on great from the start never saw him be
rude to anyone
but I'm told Mr Ralph's Behavior changed
depending on who he was dealing with he
would adapt his behavior depending on
the person so if you weren't important
he's absolutely awful and he'd pivot to
being reasonable and affable say with
the PM or another senior figure
Rob wasn't a nice person and he was a
bully and really hard to work for
today fresh questions about what the PM
knew about the allegations against his
deputy and when can the minister clarify
here today did the cabinet office warn
the Prime Minister about the conduct of
the Deputy Prime Minister before he was
reappointed to the cabinet I thought the
labor party believed in due process the
due process is that Adam Tully a very
senior KC is investigating all aspects
of that the reality is the minister is
protecting a corrupt standards regime
upheld by the conservatives for the last
13 years with the Prime Minister as
judge and Jory the prime minister is the
final adjudicator in this inquiry Adam
Tolley may present the evidence but it's
the PM who decides what flows from it
the Hope from allies is that it will
least be a decision that's in black or
white but whatever happens there will be
problems if Dominic Robb goes the Prime
Minister will face questions as to why
he put him into cabinet in the first
place and what exactly did he know when
if he stays well there could be a
backlash potentially from the Civil
Service and there could be questions too
about Rishi sunak and whether he really
is a prime minister of integrity
Dominic Robs a close political Ally of
Mr sunac whatever the outcome of this
inquiry this a headache for the PM Beth
Rigby Sky News